you know when you see a video that pops
up online and it's like European Union's
head of Finance or whatever and it's
like we're digitizing the Euro and now
we're going to be overseeing all
transactions and we're going to be the
ones that get to dictate what you can
and can't do with your money basically
they're going to be the ones that set
the limits on your freedom when you see
that video that's a light hologram so be
fearless and God
punch punch those Matrix tentacles
fearlessly punch them same thing when
someone replies to you in person or
online or wherever someone replies to
you and they're like oh I'm a beta cck I
like getting the jobs or I believe in
daddy government or whatever
Roar at them
fearlessly Roar at them fearlessly for
New Earth Roar at them Roar at them
because it's just a light hologram it's
just a light hologram
that's where this fearlessness can come
from that's why you can feel like you're
wielding these
[Music]
swords feel like you're wielding those
swords that have etched on them new
Earth or bust you know I'm going to die
on this sword of new Earth